[Music]
hi everybody and welcome back i'm james
powell
you may know me as co-chair of the num
focus board of directors
you may know me as vice president of pi
data with a purview over all
global pi data conferences and meetups
or you might know me as the guy at the
python conferences in the suit
i'm really excited to speak to aaron
richter a data scientist at saturn cloud
today
aaron's going to share with us a little
bit about how saturn cloud and early
sage startup
has invested in the pi data ecosystem
and the open source scientific computing
ecosystem
but i also want to share with you a
little detail i know one of the founders
of saturn cloud hugo
i've known hugo for a couple of years
now and i've known that
even before founding saturn cloud hugo
has had an investment
and an interest in supporting the open
source scientific computing ecosystem
the pi data ecosystem and the pi data
community so i'm
very excited to hear more from aaron
about what saturn cloud is up to
so aaron would you like to introduce
yourself to all of our pi data global
attendees
watching this from home sure hi my name
is aaron richter i'm a data scientist
data engineer started off as a software
developer and kind of
came into the data science world right
when the big data
wave was taking over so i did a lot of
distributed computing back in the day
i did a lot of machine learning and data
science
in the pi data ecosystem now i'm a
senior data scientist at saturn cloud
saturn cloud is an end-to-end
data science and machine learning
platform for data scientists and their
teams to take the most advantage of the
pi data ecosystem
and scale that on using das and rapids
so
my focus at saturn cloud is to ensure
that people know
how to use these tools most effectively
and i also help clients
kind of migrate some of their maybe
single node python workloads into
cluster computing
or gpu computing we're all about making
it really easy for people to accelerate
their workloads
abstracting away a lot of infrastructure
and hardware setup so that way data
scientists can focus on writing code
building models creating visualizations
and then creating value at their
companies
erin tell me a little bit about what
open source tools
especially tools from the pi data stack
that you all use at saturn cloud
yeah so we we do a lot in the open
source and
pi data community there's a couple
places where we use the tools
one in our product and then ways that we
enable our users
to take advantage of open source tools
so in the product
we use things like docker and kubernetes
for containerization
hosting all of our apps and we'll
utilize a lot of
the open source das and jupiter
components
because that's part of our product
offering and then for the web app we use
vue js what's your favorite open source
project my favorite open source project
in the like pi data community and really
focusing on the
accelerated computing space i would say
is rapids
i think that's really exciting because
it's pushing all of this data science
computation
onto the gpu and you see a lot of
performance increases and
i personally really believe that this is
the future of kind of accelerated
computing
and data science computing it just makes
sense to do your stuff on the gpus
because it's faster
saturn cloud also uses condo forge quite
heavily how does conda fit into this
environmental management
strategy yeah and so one of the one of
the ways that we support defining an
environment is through a conda
environment file so you can copy and
paste your yaml that you would normally
use
for like a conda and create and that's
typically the way that i really create a
lot of my environments and that we
recommend as well
because that way conda is doing the
solving it's figuring out which packages
are compatible it'll let you know if
there are incompatibilities and then
we'll kind of
take over that part you know once condo
has created that python environment
we'll make sure that that gets hooked up
into the docker
and that way you know all of your nodes
are now using the same
environment so i know saturn cloud is a
fairly young company
but has already made a name for itself
contributing to
the pi data community after all you're
one of our sponsors for pi data global
what motivates saturn cloud to be
a contributor to the community in this
way from the very birth of the company
yeah so from the beginning we have
always been
full on open source pi data community
it's really
part of our business success our entire
goal is to ensure that data scientists
and data science teams
can successfully use the pi data
ecosystem scale
their code with desks so we wanted to
make sure
that we were contributing from the
beginning because we're relying
and relying on top of these awesome
packages we want to make sure that we
can continue to contribute to them
by actually adding code to them
contributing to events and pushing
forward
the community because this is really
honestly it's central to our business
so not only is it makes sense
commercially for us because if these
open source packages are good people are
going to continue to use saturn
but also we truly believe in
these packages and in this community
because it has such a great impact
across
all businesses when we can do good data
science so from from those two aspects
that's why we've always been
kind of open source first from the
beginning so what would you say to a
colleague at a similarly sized
early stage startup to try to convince
them to
employ their limited resources to better
engagement with the community
yeah i would say from the beginning it's
open source is awesome because there are
so many different people working on
different problems you can usually find
an open source package that solves your
problem
but that all of the reason that that
open source package
exists is because somebody was
passionate about it someone was spending
their time
sometimes even their nights and weekends
on working on that package
you know we've we hear stories a lot of
some of the top
open source packages have three or five
core maintainers
who have kind of been doing this on the
side or on a volunteer basis so
if you think about all the money as a
business that you would spend
on on tools for you know email
and and managing all of your your
employees and
any other thing where you you would kind
of like spend money on a commercial
offering
you get this open source stuff for free
but
it still requires people to contribute
and people who create that so from the
beginning
it kind of just makes sense to
contribute there also
you want to make sure that this open
source tool that you might be depending
on
is going to stick around for the future
that there if bugs are going to come out
they can be fixed so first if you can
kind of
contribute to the package financially
you can know that there will be people
there funded to
to kind of work on those things and even
better if you can commit
an employee or resource on your team to
contributing directly to those packages
you now
know that it's gonna it's going to kind
of be stable you know if something goes
wrong somebody's right in there
talking to the maintainers working with
them and they can get it fixed that has
happened a lot for us at saturn is
you know i would run into a problem with
desk and then i would kind of talk to
some of my colleagues and they're like
oh yeah i saw that issue
just three days ago and there are these
people working on it and it really helps
a lot to be that well connected to a
community especially for packages that
you really count them
so let me ask you this if you were
interviewing for a new job
and the company asked you what excites
you most about this position
how would you try to convince them to
increase their contribution open source
or even start contributing to open
source how would you try and convince
them that it's worthwhile
for you as a new hire to be more
invested in open source
yeah i think especially thinking about
the being in the space of
kind of tools focused work
i would really want to convince any sort
of employer or my future employer
to commit to open source because first
of all
it creates this authority in the
community
so when when people see that your staff
members are actually contributing to
these open source packages that they're
using
when they're answering their questions
when they're fixing bugs it shows that
you as a company
actually know what you're doing are
investing
in this tool and then people who want to
buy whatever product or service
you're offering have a lot more trust in
what you're doing because you are
there at the core building kind of in
the weeds making sure everything's
working
so aaron pi data global is not the first
pi data
conference that you've attended outside
of just the software
pi data to a lot of people means a
community of like-minded users
what interests you or excites you or
engages you most about the pi data
community
pi data has been an awesome community
for me my
first exposure to it was through the pi
data miami group that's actually
relatively new and i was able to help
kind of build that up be part of the
organizing efforts
and do a conference here but i would say
that this paid community
probably is the the biggest community
thing that
even gave me my job at saturn i wouldn't
have known about saturn cloud but i
actually met saturn cloud
through pi data before i even started
working there so
for me personally it's been a great
avenue for my own career growth
i've been able to meet awesome people
that even people who have
created big open source packages and
these kind of
more celebrity names that you would hear
and see on twitter or
kind of see contributing to packages and
like wow you know those people are
really smart and doing awesome things
i'm able to either sit in the same room
with them meet them talk to them see
them at different conferences
virtually currently um but i think the
pi data community has been really great
for this entire ecosystem of tools but
even just as a data scientist trying to
kind of progress my career meet people
network
it's it's been an awesome community if
you knew somebody who is interested in
applying to work at saturn cloud
what might you tell them to take that
from merely interested to
really excited i'd say if you want to
be able to contribute to the future
of data science and the future of
accelerated computing
you should apply to work at saturn cloud
we're on the cutting edge
of a lot of tools that i really believe
are going to change the way that people
interact with data and compute with data
so you should definitely check us out
so in addition to contributing back to
the projects what else does saturn cloud
do
to contribute back to the community yeah
so saturn is really
committed to not only the code but also
to the community of people
that are learning all of these tools so
we especially in
these covent times all the meetups have
gone virtual so we've helped to
host and sponsor some pi data meetups
particularly with the new york city
miami and philadelphia groups and we've
been working on helping
getting speakers helping getting
software and making sure that those
communities can continue to kind of keep
moving forward as well so
i'm excited to participate in those and
make sure that
these community meetups can still keep
going forward and that we can actually
talk to some people in different cities
that we might normally have not done
before
so aaron thank you for joining us today
i really enjoyed hearing more about how
saturn cloud has invested in the das
ecosystem and i'm really looking forward
to seeing your talk at pi data global
thank you very much i really enjoyed
this i'm really looking forward to
interacting with everybody at the pi
data global conference
[Music]
you